my name is Hassan I'm a bouncer in New
York City tonight we're going to find
out who's under 21 in this line I've
worked at different clubs I've worked
with specific artists like cardi B and
she came back to lust but really what I
did was make sure the youngins didn't
get in the club so tonight we're going
to find out who the Imposter is in this
line
hey how you feeling awesome sorry I had
you standing online so long we got a lot
of a lot of activities going on a quick
question for you um what year did you
graduate high school
2015 2015. sure
yes I remember
you in college
I I went to college yeah you went to
college yeah
do me a favor can go to the back of line
for me okay I'll get back to you
simple tells when somebody gets online I
shouldn't beat it they like to avoid eye
contact most people avoid all natural
behaviors because in the back of their
mind they're like I don't want to get
caught or I've already been caught next
up
how you feeling
okay you ready to go away
sure ready to get a drink yeah yeah are
you all another drink yeah how old are
you I'm 25. you're 25. what are you born
uh 98
98. I didn't know that was a year yeah
it's a year well that's why I should be
going through
um like other bars in there you've been
to Sunshine over there
[Music]
uh no I haven't no
sunshines don't exist can you go to the
back of line for me how you doing this
evening I'm good you look like you had
to trick somebody hmm
what's your favorite drink I love vodka
anyways that's usually my go-to [ __ ]
family when the first time you had a
drink uh recently actually you didn't
have a drink until you turned 21.
[Music]
I wasn't a huge Drinker no I respect you
won't do the right thing yeah yeah so
most people do the right thing how you
doing this evening doing good what are
you doing 1989 1989 oh you like me We up
there saying I don't see no crow's feet
but you look like you use a moisturizer
what's using your face lotion lotion
that's it
[Music]
some name right go to back online for me
let me get back to you how you doing
this evening
who are your friends they got a table
yeah they do they got tickets yeah how
old are you 25. did you go to college I
did you did what year did you graduated
2019
straight out yeah took that career
series for sure what'd you do for work
I'm a media strategist media strategist
yeah
that sounds like I might need to work
with you yeah you might okay well we're
trying to figure out what's going on a
lot do we feel go to back online I'm
gonna get back to you step on up my
friend I am 22. since when since 1999.
once you graduate high school when yeah
uh 2019 2019 yeah what was your favorite
show as a kid
I like that so raven what do you like to
visit
um usually any queer place like well I
know a few uh
the queue oh yeah Hotel oh that closed
uh closed down uh
you want to go to the back of the line
we'll get back to you
how you doing I'm good what year were
you born 97 97. what year did you
graduate high school 2015 2015 not 2013.
no no no not 2017. no that wouldn't be
the right year just ask no no I
understand did you go to college yes
what college you go through NYU NYU
[Music]
hard worker
yo what's your favorite cartoon as a kid
I wasn't allowed to watch cartoons
were you a Mormon no my parents when I
don't know I was never allowed to watch
SpongeBob The Simpsons anything all
right we gonna find out if you need
pasta go to back online for me we'll get
back with you in a minute now that I've
talked to everybody in line I'm gonna
figure out who's gonna get in the club
who's not getting
so I can't let you win
finally you can't come in this club okay
maybe in a year or two next up
I might be slopping you on her route but
I need you to go over there for now
champ
okay what's up hi how you feeling I'm
good you better not be the Imposter no
I'm not are you sure I mean that's up to
you to decide
I'm gonna let you go up in there go get
a drink don't start no problem first
thank you
Mr 30s Mr 30s I'm not gonna waste your
time sir go up in there enjoy your night
here let me get you up in there I'ma let
you go in tonight thank you don't fool
me wrong
step on up my friend how are you I'm
good how are you welcome back to the
line thank you how old are you I am 22.
it's a good choice go on and enjoy your
drink all right thank you don't start no
problems thank you next up hey what's up
how you feeling better than ever I'm
gonna let you go have a drink tonight I
would really love that I really hope
you're not being positive I hope for you
that's the truth I hope so too
all right so I picked them too just
basically because of the stuttering uh
it seemed too too too off tilt I'm going
to take the chance and let you win
because you seem to have the eyes that
show you might be a little bit closer to
the truth I'm gonna let you enjoy your
drink tonight and I'm pretty sure this
is my imposter I'm sorry you can't come
in not tonight young lady
hopefully when you're of age
hey son how do you think you did
you think I nailed it
I hope I nailed it
welcome back thank you I'm 25. 25. thank
you enjoy your drinks
you again yes how old are you I'm 28.
[Music]
flabbergasted 28. yeah
hello again hi how old are you I'm funny
too okay so you should be here
enjoy
it's the 30s you better not tell me
you're 17 and would be very upset how
old are you my friend 32 32 let's go you
should be here having drinks with me in
fact we shouldn't be here we threw over
this what are we doing
hello guys Hi how are you I'm 25. 25.
we're getting to the truth all right of
these two what do you think
my friend right here on the left how old
are you I'm 20. it's
can't come in tonight
I'd like to get my drink now enjoy your
drink
you won yeah you won the game of the
night because you got us in my club
underage and all do you do this often um
I do not very good very good do me a
favor wait 221 and pop back out okay
I'll wait bye guys